alright so when did you hear that
something was up with Laremy Tunsil I'm
a few friends of mine texted and Mayock
came to pounded his phone and he says to
me during one of the commercial breaks
are you hearing what's going on with
tonsil I then googled Tunsil and a
photograph of a gas mask with a bomb
sticking out of it pops up and I'm like
all right I've done now 12 drafts and
I've never I've never had to okay now
now let me go Google bong hit okay I
mean that's this is I've never been
anywhere in this sort of territory and
then towards the end of the draft we
found out his Instagram got hacked with
a much more with much more serious
ramifications I mean obviously the gas
mask in the marijuana is something that
cost him 12 spots in the draft
potentially not not really obviously
from one but he was the guy who is when
we left the combine everybody thought
was going to be number one overall
selection but really from 3 to 13
costume 10 draft spots potentially
that's one thing but the the accusations
that will Malcolm is not really
accusations it's clear that something
was going on at Ole Miss and and that
that has far-reaching but how do you
cover this rich with it you have to
validate it but its cover it's changing
the draft in real time it is well I mean
I we talked about it obviously I even
took a little bit of heat of saying you
know after Ian Rapoport said that the
agents saying it's a video that's five
years old and then went took a look at
it again I'm like that that did not to
me look like a high school kid in that
video did not look five years old at all
to me and I said that on the air you
know so I'm just giving my opinion in
the real time that I that that does not
look five years old it does not look
fake to me and this is something that
clearly some teams had to be dealing
with on the spot the Ravens taking him
completely off their draft board and you
know it's not just
the pot smoking is that that's not
that's more like a man bites dog story
right in years ago now it's now it's a
lot more normal when you hear the kid
this is smoking weed it's all the other
things too like why would you let
somebody videotape you why would you
have it still why would you have such a
horrible password that it gets hot not
only on that account but your Instagram
account why whatwhat decision-making
skills are you going to make from here
on out do you extrapolate it further and
it's interesting that there's a team
that had major issues in their offensive
line meeting room a couple of years ago
normally that would lead to a team
taking any kid at that position off
their draft board and they the Dolphins
are all in and he's a terrific talent
and if he could you know straighten
himself out not make mistakes and
protect Tamil they got themselves a gold
a golden pick at 13 we had Daniel
Jeremiah on and you know here's a former
NFL scout and he said what happens in
the draft room you have the owner there
it's not like you can go we have a week
to sort this out soften it a little bit
it's it's live right that you can't go
yep found our guy what the guy with the
mask in the bong yeah yeah that's our
guy and the owner is there so he said if
this is a week prior then maybe but he
says Miami got a steal got the best
player in the draft I mean we left the
combine all of us saying the layers of
the first overall pick is Larry Tunsil
because it fit obviously the Titans need
and how good he is and so he's still
that same football player and he's there
at 13 again what decisions will he make
living in south beach from here on out
is this the concern but if they have no
concerns over that or they have a plan
in place and then he's going to they got
themselves a heck of a tackle last night
Rich Eisen NFL network they had their
coverage rounds two and three coming up
tonight the biggest reaction in Chicago
when this player was selected the zoo
last night
hmm I guess I mean when the Bears took
Floyd I mean that really didn't like the
room up there really wasn't one last
night where the whole place went crazy I
guess might have been Paxton Lynch it
could have been that Dan I mean a
make-a-wish kid amounts to pick you know
as nice a moment in the room and then it
was a quarterback taken late it was also
interesting that it that the young man
left the stage it was a nice moment they
put the Packers on the clock and
everybody boo'd like crazy completely
different direction yeah and they booed
the Commissioner with every pic to every
time every time was just no no two ways
about it and then I also say this Dan
every time he did leave the stage there
were tons of fans that wanted to take
pictures with him and it's going to
happen again tonight he's going to be
there all friday night in the minute he
walks into the crowd it's not like he's
a pariah but I but when it's the
collective masses at yes that was a it
was lustily booing every single town we
walked out there and the bro hugs you're
going on too long there you know if
that's if that's exactly if that's a
Catholic dance eighth grade dance the
nun is stepping in between the two it's
you're talking to it you right now but I
hear you I hear you on that front you
know it's it's it's it's interesting
when you said also at the top here you
know did you do know that I don't know
because you might have been fixed on the
ESPN coverage because you expect to hear
the word motor for bosa yeah I did bring
up Jeff Spicoli to may uck oh yes I saw
that yeah I saw that guy yeah cuz um we
weren't sure cuz my aunt came on the
show yesterday he said bozzo reminds me
of Spicoli and I said you got to mention
that he goes no no I'm just gonna I'll
just mention our show I took care of
that I loved it and what but I got to be
honest with you had the tonsil video
come out before that I don't think I
would have amazing Spicoli river so the
timing worked out perfectly good well
you also gave us a Cheech and Chong
reference which was well done by you
drop that you know I think though you
should if I may get involved in DP show
affairs okay I think you should tease
Polly's death to Monday justice us
out if one of the other day Nets would
make that the best of the weekend on
Monday just to see what's going on if if
you had to vote yes Paulie had a good
run it but if you had I mean he did bet
he bet his life that JJ watt's name
would be mentioned or on my kind of
video if you had to vote for Paulie
losing his life do you mean I'm on the
holy holy roman emperor and yes this is
this is uh yeah this is uh let let Polly
live let Polly live oh he made a mistake
he it's like tonsil it's it's five years
old right know if she made a mistake
what do you think Satan well we did just
get a suggestion that I like a lot that
I think is is very likely to come true
and that was that the inevitable
collapse of the 2016 Cubs will kill
Pauly naturally people here are fired up
they're fired up for the White Sox too
by the way yeah there they got they got
their cubs here it's it's been a fun
week here in Chicago everybody's been
loving the draft here again and but the
Cubs and White Sox fans are all lit up
for sure on here literally you know I
guess I gotta watch my phrasing these
days you know especially tonight I
cannot believe that happened last night
I really cannot believe this is what we
were talking about during an NFL and so
had somebody had to show that video to
the Commissioner last night to that
video had to be shown in at some point
and that that's not an interesting rich
you know the Commissioner will say you
didn't see that video you think so it's
not out it oh no it's it that's a ray
rice shot my bad nevermind oh no
distance yourself from me because he
doesn't come on the show yeah he does
not know there's collateral damage right
yeah get out while you can rig up a
great job last night we'll be watching
tonight and coverage starts at what time
um five minutes ago you're on the clock
no Browns are Honor we have urban meyer
on the set tonight and he'll be
mean year to year the whole time it was
really unbelievable five of the first 20
Oh hast a pic so it's me him Charles
Davis in May och tonight I'm thinking
I'm trying to do the math right here but
it's five o'clock eastern six o'clock
eastern shuttle around there they just
they don't bleed one to the next right
now dance and can you give Urban Meyer a
high five he was left hanging last night
I saw that so I saw that yeah I'll do
that yeah Buffy wants it for me because
again you know I mean that whole no
Michigan Ohio State yeah yeah my guys on
my show want me to introduce him his
urban ire tonight because he doesn't
like it when the end gets pronounced
look right out of the gate what do you
think Dani Beck who is hiring too hard
right up again you might put him on his
heels a little bit though Danny and I'm
he's coming on our show for it's like
five hours to I mean that would be a
long five hours to start off that way
yeah you can't invite somebody over to
dinner and then make fun of them like
it's it's frowned upon not until dessert
like if you've had enough wine or beer
then you can but okay yeah I don't think
I'd have a shot fired early okay
backseat think thanks for having my back
on that then I wanted to go in your
direction and and by the way your boy
coupe is sitting out there watching
without his tonsils this morning
listening to tell your son God is just
tonsils taken home right it probably is
your son day to day my son is already
back in action he's unbelievable right
now Cooper is some bounce back ability
that we're real proud of right now so
you sitting there is it but but Xander I
do believe is enjoying all the ice cream
that's coming in like that now yeah by
proxy you get it to go yeah absolutely
love watching their Uncle Dan um all
right have fun tonight and uh we'll talk
to you soon appreciate it all right
that's rich eisen the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience